the weather matches the mood in the
labour party here in concert near durham
after the conservatives won in
hartlepool gained northumberland council
and won seats on councils across the
northeast
david toner stood as a councillor here
for labour he lost to a conservative the
first time that's ever happened
my personal feeling is that labour has
become
in the things that i found when i was
out knocking doors labour's become the
party of the youth it's become the party
of the
educators the young the young people the
people with small kids the people who
were looking for a future
they were all voting labor the old
feel disenfranchised they want change
and they think the tories are going to
give it to them
labour's done pretty badly in areas like
concert and across the northeast
and it's a pattern that's been repeated
around the country and it's been
happening slowly for some time
there's a real sense that the party that
used to understand communities like this
doesn't anymore
and they're willing to give the
conservatives a go instead and labor's
done much better in big cities like
manchester but that poses a problem
because the party has to appeal to
voters whose interests are quite
different
and as yet it doesn't know how to do
that
andy burnham's mayoral win in manchester
is a bright spot for labour
therefore i declare that andy burnham is
duly elected
as the mayor of the greater manchester
combined authority
but even he had some harsh truths for
his party
there has to be substantial change in
the way the labour party is
is working they have lost an emotional
connection with parts of the country
that
you know is going to take a lot of work
to get back so i think the party has to
do a lot of soul searching about
these results and understand why we've
done well in places like wales places
like greater manchester
and it really needs to then you know buy
into
english devolution and build from the
bottom up that's what these results are
telling them
as did mark drakeford in wales where the
party held on to power
i know that securistama will want to
have a review of
these elections across the united
kingdom we'll be very
keen to contribute to that and if there
are any things that
we've been able to do in wales that
would be of interest to others of course
we'll be there to do so
and it seems the first lesson sakirshama
has learned is that he needs a new team
around him sacking his party chair
angela raynor
a move which has upset some on the
labour left but the party's collapse
across its former red wall is an
opportunity for the conservatives i
think the real attitudinal change to
labour has been
that people just traditionally voted for
them you went to the ballot station you
did what your dad told you when you
first voted your mum told you
and you and you kept voting for them and
i think people have started to really
question that i think we've got to
deliver on it
and i you know i've made it very clear
to the all the local
candidates who stood for us you know
this isn't you know we are not going to
be like the labour councillors who went
before them
we're going to be active local
councillors as with an active local mp
and that's the test for boris johnson
can he in the wake of a pandemic really
deliver change here
for kyostrama's labour the question is
more fundamental
regrowing the party's northern roots may
take years
kate mccann sky news